many are called but few are chosen why
because few believe God will not choose
and use you if you don't believe finish
the context did you read Matthew 22:14
in context see yeah brother I'm
answering it right now this is also a
passage distorted by Calvinists because
our Lord himself said in Matthew 7:13-14
narrow is the path of Salvation and few
shall enter it wide is the gate to
destruction and many shall find it if
you read in context he's not saying oh
many are called but only God has chosen
a few to be saved that's not the
contextual meaning can you open up
Matthew 22 because you're reading 14 can
you read Matthew 22 for me vers 1- 13
see what he meant in
context can you read it uh yeah just
just a second yeah don't be a calvinist
not me brother save yourself from
Calvinism don't go through the hell of
Calvinism no no no I'm I'm not a
calvinist no no but I'm just saying
because the way you sound it's like
you're being influenced by calvinistic
predeterminism and it's not biblical I'm
just letting you know been there done
that re the T-shirt go to Matthew 22
when you open it up let me know now now
read 14 for me before you read the
context for many are called but few are
chosen that's what you refer to right uh
yeah I mean that it was also the uh the
parable that gave but the same thing
even the parable is still the same point
that's what you're referring to but now
read Matthew 221 to 13 my book now you
read 14 right now read verses 1 or
13 Jesus Jesus also told them other
Parables he said the Kingdom of Heaven
can be illustrated by the story of a
king who prepared a great wedding Feast
for his son when the banquet was ready
he sent his servants to notify now
Parable that explains many are called
few are chosen notice the parable a king
gives a banquet for a son and does
what uh prepares a great wedding feast
okay keep going don't stop oh uh when
the banquet was ready he sent his
servants to notify those who were
invited and but they all refused to come
wait so he invited folks to come and
they refused to
enter uh yeah that's so does that mean
they were predestined or he wanted to
come but because they didn't want to
come they're no longer part of the
chosen because they rejected the
call right yeah is that the meaning
contextually y yeah now keep reading
don't stop uh so he sent other servants
to tell them the feast has been prepared
the B and the fattened uh cattle have
been killed and everything is ready come
to the banquet but the guests had he had
invited ignored them and went their own
way one
to he called many invited many and some
say they come but when it came time to
show up they refuse that's why few are
chosen cuz only the ones who accept the
invitation and attend will be
chosen okay um can I keep reading though
don't stop uh others seized his
Messengers and insulted them and killed
them the King was fous and he sent it
again others seized SE seized his
Messengers and insulted them and killed
them so the ones that he
invited killed The Messengers who came
to invite them to the wedding Feast of
the
sun y so he wanted even these people to
show up but their response was the hell
with your banquet we could care less for
your son and Jesus talking about himself
I am the Son of God God is my father and
the father wants you to come and attend
the wedding Feast of me his beloved
Son okay yep yep okay keep going uh the
King was Furious and he sent out his
army to destroy the murderers yeah and
he said to his servants the wedding
Feast is ready and the guests I've
invited aren't worthy of the honor did
you catch it yeah the wedding Feast of
my
son now takes place number one number
two those who were invited were not
worthy of the invitation because they
rejected it so were they not worthy
because they were predestined for
deamination or they were not worthy
because by rejecting to come they showed
they
okay now finish it keep going now go out
to the street corners and invite
everyone you see so the servants brought
in everyone they could find good and bad
alike and the banquet hall was filled
with guests but when the king came in to
meet the guests he noticed a man who was
who wasn't wearing the proper clothes
for a wedding friend he asked now let me
explain what that means okay watch it
was the duty of
the host of The Wedding to provide
wedding garments for those who attended
so here's someone who showed up and he
didn't have the wedding garment that
goes with someone being invited so you
come there here's your garment boom and
so they're looking at him hey friend how
did you get here it's obvious you're not
invited because your garment shows
you're not invited because if you were
then you'd have the proper attire how
did you get her you know what that means
by the way is this talking about like
the people living Two Worlds you know
trying to be a Christian as well living
in the world no that's not what it means
reread it
again then the king said to his
attendees uh bind his hands and feet and
throw him into the outer Darkness where
there will be weeping and nashing of
teeth and then for many are called but
few are chosen ah now we get the context
right yeah yep okay now
what does it mean in Matthew 22213 there
was a man who didn't have proper wedding
attire because the point of Jesus is The
Wedding Banquet refers to the kingdom of
Christ right yep yeah now that person
signifies individuals who try to enter
the Kingdom of Heaven through another
way other than
Christ you understand
oh so it it isn't talking about like
people trying to live Two
Worlds it's talking about people who are
trying to find another way to sneak into
the kingdom without coming through
Christ and accepting Christ and this
would be a shot at the Jews the
Pharisees the scribes the teachers of
the law who think they will enter the
kingdom by rejecting the
son that's why said
friend reread 12 and 13 again because I
want you to see what he did not say
friend he asked how is it that you were
here without wedding clothes but the man
had no reply and the King said to his
tendies bind his hands and feet and
throw him into the outer Darkness where
there will be did you find anywhere
there that the
the the king said friend why are you
here you're not invited
no that's that did he say why are you
here you're not
invited no that's no not once nope you
guys caught it he didn't say to that man
hey why you here you were not invited
because God invites everyone what he's
the said is that he entered through
another means another way and he thought
the king would be pleased with
it you understand the
point yeah yeah the message is there's
only one way to enter into the kingdom
of Jesus by accepting an invitation to
trust in Jesus and worship him as your
lord and savior as God's beloved Son
otherwise you cannot enter so if you're
a Jew who rejects Jesus and think
because you're a religious Jew an
orthodox Jew you'll enter you got a
thing coming if you're a Muslim or a
Hindu and think you can enter the
kingdom apart from accepting invitation
to believe in Jesus Christ you got
another thing coming because whether you
guys like it or not the kingdom is the
kingdom of the Son of God and if you
want to reign in the Kingdom you better
accept the son of the king because the
son of the king is the king of the
Kingdom okay now in that context where
do you get that God only predestined a
few to be saved when the passage is the
opposite God called everyone as many as
he could only a few responded and
they're the ones chosen to reign with
with his son in his kingdom